[Music]
a man took a selfie with his wife by the
edge of a cliff oh oh what do you think
happens next they both fell you pushed
her
why would you go to that you're cr does
that happen this is this is wholesome
news
so we're only talking about good things
happening to people got murdered this
person got murdered so at least it
wasn't a child
no this one's innocent this one's one of
those hey honey we should take one of
those pictures right jumping in the end
yeah
like and then they did
the outside of the outside of the cliff
and then they jump backwards
backwards yeah that's just bad but they
got a good shot though yeah so yeah um
he takes a selfie with her at the edge
of the cliff and yep then he pushes her
off oh what was the point of taking a
picture with her to be like we were just
taking pictures that she slipped and
fell he wanted to tell the story saying
that they were taking a photo together
and then so that was the alibi
he shoved her off the cliff but he was
on video mode so then the cop captured
the whole thing it was a it was a live
photo it was a live photo so you just
like
you bro and they those things capture
[ __ ] sounds
and then he picked the one that he
wanted and it was her like in mid-air
getting pushed it was him like this yeah
so um what actually happened was yeah
she died oh
she wanna know what else stops it off
what she's pregnant oh
she's pregnant maybe that's why and he
pushed her off the cliff to cash in on
their accident insurance and seven loans
that he had taken out for
life insurance
loans and life
insurance damn
why seven you couldn't like maybe that's
gonna maximum maximize this murder
that's not fishy at all that's the limit
what was the payout do you know oh is it
turkey um yeah the payout well they
don't know all the loans but um it says
like 21 000 pounds was like one of the
payouts for the accident insurance i
didn't even know you could have so many
loans out that totals did was he able to
he he actually got the money
um i i don't think it got that far but
what happened was it he almost got away
with it it was for you meddling kids
it's one of those situations where like
um that's the story like oh she fell
blah blah blah and then later on i mean
check this photo out so that's um that's
the photo of them on the top right there
oh my god that's so crazy is that the
last moment could be yeah
it sucks because look how happy she
looks i know i mean that's a beautiful
view too you finally took me where i
wanted to go but isn't that like so
crazy if you're gonna try to murder
somebody right what i understand you're
trying to get all this money from
murdering somebody but it's like it's
the easiest way to get [ __ ] pops
right yeah especially if you're trying
to claim an accident dumb criminals like
whoever gets away with the [ __ ] just
leave the relationship
because we only hear about the ones that
get caught oh [ __ ]
yeah so what happens is that um
you know you think he's gonna have a
clean getaway and then
bing bong new angle of someone else
recording them oh
wait someone else was watching the whole
thing another guy had a weird feeling
about it when he saw him like at the
edge of the cliff with her maybe because
he was watching him and going honey go
go further out and all yeah yeah go down
over here okay great ready no no no
further out next to those really sharp
rocks you actually made a joke like
while he was like filming him like yo
either he's gonna push her off or she's
gonna put like it was like one of those
funny things oh [ __ ] he actually
happened and he recorded him pushing her
off i don't know if he recorded the
actual push because they don't show that
or anything like he didn't get the
moments right before if anything and
then what'd he do send it to the police
i think once the yeah i think like once
that case kind of like uh
went up then he was like yo i think
these are the dudes
oh wait so he didn't see the push
i think he saw that i'm not sure it
doesn't matter that's kind of weird how
he recorded the whole thing and then
goes yeah that's crazy and he walked
away now you just see that
pusher
yeah man
oh look i'm nick
but i think like what happened was they
like the family of the wife was really
really like suspicious of him obviously
it sounds like a dick but also just the
he had all the textbook behaviors of
someone that's not remorseful about your
wife dying which i think is the biggest
[ __ ] up in a lot of people trying to
conceal murder is they just don't have
the emotions to match it that was his
thing what would you guys do if your
you know son or daughter brought in a
[ __ ] idiot like this into your
family oh
that's so cause you just have these
feelings you're just like i don't know
about this one man i i mean i love you
but [ __ ] i hate your [ __ ] spouse yeah
damn i don't know you might just have to
make their life a living hell hopefully
they leave what
that's a good one or take them to it
i don't like you
because i feel like sometimes when you
when you're
when you tell somebody that type of like
oh i don't like your other like yeah it
pushes them away even harder and
especially
if you're seeing stuff that's like
that's like sketchy you're just like
this is not cool kind of thing yeah then
you take them to a fishing trip and you
come back without them yeah i don't know
he felt he fell in the water trying to
take a selfie but then they fell off
yeah it's it's dicey because like
sometimes when you try to like scare a
guy
like he'll take it out on the girl yeah
what do you mean
if you scare him like if like a father
scaring a
the girl's boyfriend he'll just be mad
that that's the dynamic he's dealing
with and he'll take it out on the girl
when the dad's not around drive like 150
miles per hour freeway because guys like
that are probably like they i'm sure
they have some weird and sometimes yeah
stuff in like weird ways and they might
even be too dumb to know that's why
they're doing it but they'll just start
treating her worse you know over that
yeah that's why
you just gotta do it you just gotta
without talking about it in a perfect
world yeah that's the key right there's
just never mentioned you gotta be cold
yeah
and right when you meet him no
discussion it's like honey i know you
love this man but um
he told me he ran away he's not coming
back
remember we did that story about that
guy his uh his daughter got murdered by
her boyfriend
and then he killed him remember he found
him killed him put him in his trunk and
i was like oh i don't know what else
yeah
and it's like that's right because he
found out that he killed the daughter oh
he sold her into sex trafficking yeah in
seattle and he just left him in the
[ __ ] car he killed him stabbed
[Music]
do we ever figure out if that was like
for sure what happened because i heard
some mixed things about like i don't
know from that for the video that we did
on jk that was a story i don't know what
happened that's what i heard i heard it
was like because the headline reads as
oh yeah sold his old girlfriend and
selected his sex trafficking so father
goes and kills him i'm like i could get
behind that and then later i heard like
uh i think he was just going off some
weird hunch or whatever and he had
nothing to do no
damn so i'm like if that's the case oh i
cannot get behind that
turn up a band cause what if this guy is
really bad at research you know i mean
like he just has he does not investigate
properly yeah yeah which could be the
case definitely blinded my range
oh my god so if that's the case which is
the only thing i'm just like ah but it's
so much cooler to think the other way
it's way it's like i said i could give
advantages
i like revenge yeah i love revenge
stories yeah that's super sad but in
this one confirmed okay kill confirm
behind killing this guy yeah he did it
he had a whole story about how it really
happened and it's [ __ ] bogus he said
he said she slipped on the bus she was
pregnant and fell over she's fat and
then she fasted she was too pregnant
with distribution just like whoa
his actual sentence is like so sus he
goes i got up and then heard my wife
scream behind me when i walked a few
steps away to get the phone from her bag
when i turned back she was not there i
did not push my wife
if he didn't say that last sentence i
did not push my wife with my life i did
not that's almost the varsity blues line
but if i were to do it i would have
pushed her i did not push my wife that's
great i mean i'm going to assume that
there's something in turkish that maybe
got translated a little bit
believe that there was some inflection
be like i didn't push my wife or like
something like that and it sounds like
he just volunteered
because if that was the answer to what
happened that's hilarious i didn't push
her right what happened i didn't [ __ ]
push her i didn't [ __ ] push her [ __ ]
don't [ __ ]
say i'll push a pregnant wife
you think i'm not kind of guy don't take
out seven loans on her ass
sir we feel sorry for your loss uh can
you tell us what happened well i didn't
push her if that's what you're saying
stop bringing it up seven loans had
nothing to do with how i didn't push my
wife no i did it but we never mentioned
well i know you were thinking about it
i don't like getting judged here so i
guess he's going to be
eligible for parole after serving at
least 30 years and then by then we'll
read the uh the headline but he's out
hopefully by that time he's too weak to
push anyone
he's out
damn dude that's wild there are [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there like that though it's
dangerous remember that netflix
documentary with the guy who killed his
uh two daughters and his wife yeah dude
[ __ ] that guy and but it was interesting
because like what was it called i forgot
it's a family in colorado yeah because
he had an affair he wanted to be with
another woman he threw his kids in like
a oil tank
he choked out everyone in the [ __ ]
house and then he just buried their
asses in the [ __ ] thing
but the whole like setup right which you
said was he kind of gave away this guy
saying like oh he was acting abnormal
about his wife falling and even in that
situation his wife is gone they have
body cam footage of the cops talking to
him and he's like yeah i just don't know
where she went yeah i just hope the kids
are all right i'm like [ __ ] you bro you
seem worried bro no crying yeah yeah
yeah they went to hide like their bodies
at his work site yeah he threw he threw
their bodies in the oil and even the
[ __ ] neighbors were like showing the
cops he did it and he was just like he
never backs his truck into his house
like this ever that's weird and i was
like damn you're these guys this guy's
not slick at all
yeah for real it's crazy to think
there's a trained person that is
watching for legitimate grief like after
a murder like there's someone like
really looking they're acting like a
live detector yeah they're asking you
stuff for a reason and they're just like
can you imagine like having someone so
are you pretty sad about what happened
but i feel like if they see people like
in those situations all the time they
they know exactly like what a normal
reaction is right so it's like and then
when you see something that just stands
out you're like this [ __ ] did it
yeah
isn't that the statistic like they
always say like the husband did it or
the scene well yeah it's usually suspect
is always the significant other usually
dude i didn't push her yeah huh i didn't
push her i want to see if i can watch
these guys grow up right what was the
progression that got them there and
usually these aren't like the first
times right like what else did they do
that they didn't get caught with oh i
see that's the things that that because
you know it's like um the whole
psychopath thing where they start with
bugs then yeah then then animals and
then
other things then hear the stories you
told by yourself
i was gonna say i was like i feel like
that's the snail was dude it's not that
snails this is burying of the frog the
progression of someone who can do sick
[ __ ] right yeah because like like i mean
like even dudes that do heists they
start with with a snicker bar
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] starts from
something
they don't go straight from target
that's a that's a college professor like
that's not someone who teaches
elementary school you gotta go like on
the steps right you gotta dabble with
your interests yeah you know what i mean
and if you do it a little bit like you
know what stealing snicker bars pursued
passion is what i'm saying is someone
who's robbing a bank that's not their
first rodeo and if it is you could
really tell because it's hilarious what
if this is their first time robbing a
bank yes everybody that's usually really
funny yeah everyone has to have their
first one but you mean that's their
first crime no no no no no oh no i'm
saying like robbing a banker the first
time yeah everyone's got to start
somewhere
the weird thing is that like he did it
in such a way that almost seems like
nobody even does it this way anymore
yeah because it's dumb
because you get [ __ ] caught yeah
because like he took out those seven
loans for her a woman who has never had
a loan in her life yeah and all the same
days all in the same weekend
she has seven
and what gets them and then dies i know
she's super [ __ ] like look at her
just she's oh god this picture is so
happy
she's so happy
what i wonder right is do people get
into relationships with the sole reason
of making money like this or do you
think they were legitimately in love one
day relationship went sour they hate
each other and then they start figuring
out ways to murder each other yeah maybe
the latter or it's like he's [ __ ]
having an affair and isn't even she's
not on his radar anymore and she's so
worried so little that all he's thinking
about is this other chick that really
wants the money and to get away or
something yeah maybe he's planning to
just scoop that money up and before they
catch on he's just out yeah and what
about just like divorce
you know what i mean like what about
like there so you have to [ __ ] kill
each other what about life keep it
simple
divorcing then working hard and making
some money and then like enjoying your
single life whatever happened with just
going out for a pack of cigarettes and
never coming back whatever happened to
that you know that's simple too that's
way better than killing your
pregnant wife pregnant watching her off
a cliff yeah bringing back going for
cigarettes so you just want to bring
back classic abandonment i think at this
point after all the stories we covered
today i think that'll be refreshing
[Laughter]
yeah at least you're giving someone a
shot just run away like a real man you
can be happy
you gotta kill anybody yeah yeah babies
unborn babies
i think from this point on i'm gonna
just be like yo dads that abandoned
their families
[Music]
you're not that bad they're not that bad
thank you for not murdering me and my
mom thank you
do